allora la parola desiderio viene da
desidera essere lontani dalle stelle
abbiamo tutti dentro di noi un anelito
un'attenzione verso qualcosa che ci
trascende siamo tutti da bambini dei
piccoli scienziati non abbiamo paura di
fare domande non abbiamo paura di
sembrare stupidi e siamo quindi degli
esploratori senza inibizioni racconta
brian greene un famoso cosmologo che un
giorno va in una classe prima alimentare
e chiede i bambini di fare un disegno
bambini cominciano c'è una bambina
particolarmente appassionata concentrata
sul suo disegno lui si avvicina dovrà
usare l'inglese si avvicina e gli dice
what are you doing ai android del face
of god difeso got no one knows the face
and growth in mille et de weert fra un
attimo lo conosceranno quindi cominciamo
così senza inibizioni
ma piano piano perdiamo questa insalata
2 destro di strade ioni nostro abbiamo
paura di osare abbiamo paura di
immaginare ora così come una vita
e chiaro che una vita senza letteratura
senza arte è una vita che comunque può
essere una vita ricca di sanza anche una
vita senza scienza può essere immaginata
quello che ci tengo al trasmettere che
perdiamo però l'opportunità di una
straordinaria esperienza una strada
nella speranza che soprattutto ci
trasforma
io parlo parlo di physical studiare
fisica comunque abbandonare il mondo
newtoniano che conosciamo dove la mela
ci casca sulla testa dove condividiamo
un senso del tempo compreso nello stesso
modo da tutti quindi entrare
nell'infinitamente piccolo della
meccanica quantistica o nell'immenso
ho descritto dalla relatività generale
ci obbliga anche solo non tanto per
capire ma anche solo per crederci
aspirare la nostra mente di andare out
of the box a rompere le catene di quei
solchi proprio per le speranze radica
noi a farlo avere questi sei gradi di
punto di vista del mondo che diventano
per un attimo 10 12 è qualcosa che ci
cambiano dopo non siamo più gli stessi
diceva il filosofo pascale il silenzio
di quegli spazi infiniti di sgomenta
io non ho scelto fisica per passione
anzi devo dire che da adolescente ero
sicuramente più attirata dalle spread e
finestre che le geometrie ero comunque
appassionata di filosofia letteratura ma
da diciottenne tormentata anche rho
quell'epoca
sentivo che fare della scrittura della
filosofia alla mia strada
mi avrebbe tenuto troppo stretta su me
stessa io avevo bisogno di tirare fuori
il baricentro di levarmelo da dentro e
di farlo vagare proprio in quegli spazi
infiniti che invece di spaventarmi gli
offrivano una dimensione oplà tante io
un istante un puntino in un universo
indifferente che però cogito ergo sum
avrei provato a scoprire
cominciamo questo viaggio allora un
attimo respiriamo un attivo di infinito
anche noi questo è quello che resta
dell'esplosione di una supernova nel
1600 è come morrone stella una stella
può morire di tanti modi il nostro sole
per esempio tra quattro miliardi di anni
si spegnerà esaurirà il suo combustibile
si espanderà diventerà una gigante rossa
si ingoierà mercurio e venere
e pari collasserà diventerà una piccola
stella nana bianca così densa con un
cucchiaino saranno 100 tonnellate se sia
molto più grandi si è si esplode e si
muore come una supernova che sposa anche
della crab nebula la carabina
addirittura su vista nel 1900 da un
cinese e sembra ritrovare spettacolare
nei colori oltretutto molto dinamica fa
30 giri su se stesse al secondo ed è
anche al risultato di un'esclusione che
ci tengo a farvi ridere a questa è
un'altra cosa da questa è la foto più
profonda che abbiamo dell'universo
questa è stata presa da bull qui c'è
l'animazione ma le immagini sono reali a
bala osservato per mesi giorni una
porzione pari al centocinquantesimo
della superficie di una luna piena e in
questa foto ci sono circa 10.000
galassie allora regola da imparare a
memoria la luce ci mette del tempo ha
viaggiato quindi ogni volta che
guardiamo indietro nello spazio
stiamo guardando nel nostro passato
ricordate lo anche ragazzi quando vedi a
quando guardiamo in cielo stellato
stiamo facendo un viaggio nel tempo
abbiamo dei poteri magici
allora il nostro nicastro a circa 13
miliardi 3 di circa 8 miliardi di anni
in questa foto ci sono dell'asse che
hanno 13 miliardi di anni fa stiamo
quasi andando a vedere l'inizio
dell'universo le primissime galassia né
formate le vediamo ci tengo a dire
questo non è fiction ne stiamo parlando
di mondi che sono altrettanto reali
quanto quello della nostra me lavezzi
cade sulla testa
le galassie che vediamo adesso la
maggior parte sono
elite e cantine sigari oppure a spirale
come la nostra via lattea le galassie
ellittiche sono galassi cannibali si
ingrossano mangiandone altre per dare
quindi un senso del della comunque
violenza anche che esiste nell'universo
questo buco nero una delle nostre
ultimissime foto quel buco nero lì in
mezzo altra stella ancora più pesante di
quella che esplodendo diventano quindi
il nostro sole piccolo come una gigante
rossa un po più grande esplodi se una
supernova ancora più grande di real time
buco nero quando muori questo buco nero
pesa circa 3 miliardi di soli quindi
queste le dimensioni di questo oggetto
questa è una bella foto di una galassia
a spirale la galassia sembrano molto
fotografica per questo l'ho ammessa
allora ecco qui ecco quei due galassie
che stanno per mangiarsi per attrazione
gravitazionale quando vanno vicino si
scompongono si tirano e ripeto
l'universo è pieno di questi di questi
casi ho tantissime foto in questo senso
nel tempo non ero tanto quindi questa è
una è una molto bella e questo mi porta
a una storia questi andromeda da una
delle galassie a noi più vicina solo 25
quintilioni di chilometri e quando noi
guardiamo le galassie le vediamo tutte
con una luce nel rosso
ciao a tutte stanno scappando e
l'universo che si espande quando quelli
all'androne da una luce nel blu ci stava
andando addosso ci sta venendo da sensi
ci stiamo andando incontro ad una
velocità di circa 100 chilometri al
secondo
oltretutto andrà nè da è anche un
guidatore molto poco estratto se l'è già
mangiata una di galassia mondo addosso e
fra quattro miliardi di anni
questo è quello che succederà però non
vi deve preoccupare il sole nel
frattempo si aspetta quindi abbiamo
altri motivi per non esserci più devo
dire che ho fatto questa prestazione
della scuola e recentemente sono stata
colpita dal fatto che mi hanno detto che
terrorizzava i ragazzi in realtà non era
allora quest'anno sono i 100 anni della
relatività generale cioè pensiamo che
nella 15a in generale solo 15 anni prima
a calvino dei padri fondatori stati
condotti da terna tinari diceva che non
c'era rimasto più niente da sapere in
fisica giusto capire come si muove alla
terra intorno al nell'etere e la
redazione di corpo nero
allora einstein a un inflessione
pazzesca praticamente l'idea è molto
semplice ne abbiamo quattro dimensioni
spazio a quattro dimensioni sapete che
oggi si parla probabilmente siamo in un
universo 11 dimensioni di cui 7
arrotolate su loro stesse però già
spaventato abbastanza richiamiamo su
quattro la presenza di materia curva lo
spazio tempio come una palla appoggiata
su un tappeto elastico questo cosa vuol
dire due cose 1 appare la gravità la
vita non è più una forza la gravità è
proprio un percorso cioè la luna intorno
alla terra o quello che si sa lottare al
tornasole non sono attratte da una forza
ma sedicente stanno facendo il cammino
che lo spazio tempo gli permette di fare
quindi sono la traiettoria nello spazio
tempo
la seconda cosa straordinaria è che
immaginate che una di queste linee 1 e
lo spazio nel tanto quindi in questo
quadratino ai per andare dai b vuole
questo tanto in presenza della materia
questo pezzettino si allunga quindi il
tempo si dilata
quindi qui sulla terra il tempo scorre
più lentamente che sulla stazione
spaziale e più lentamente che se invece
ci allontanano
ancora di più quelli sono tenuto alla
nostra quindi viviamo in un mondo dove
il tempo si flette si curva cambia non
solo secondo la velocità ma anche in
presenza di una massa diceva lo
scrittore lambert est non basta a
smontare un orologio per capire cos'è il
tanto sicuramente non basta ma voglio
sottolineare un punto
immaginarsi queste cose come ci si
arriva come si fa a pensare in questo
modo così rivoluzionario ha quindi
l'importanza del counter tim kring peter
thiel e il fondatore di linkedin di
paypal
quando fate colloquio di lavoro chiede
questa domanda qual è quella verità
fondamentale in cui voi credete
e su cui nessun altro d'accordo domanda
difficilissima interessante vedere le
risposte che tiene una domanda
fondamentale per due motivi uno perché
pensare noi comunque abbiamo sapere
concordato è quello che ci insegna la
scuola non siamo scaraventati fuori
mondi dove appunto dobbiamo immaginare
motivo ma non è solo questa di essere
brillanti e saper pensare controcorrente
e anche avere il coraggio di rischiare
l'impopolarità cioè di perdere il
consenso attraverso ciò che si è pensato
e che contro corrente
quindi questa è una donna fondamentali
anni che da sempre una voce avreste
creduto che l'operaio rotonda io ci
avrei creduto che votiamo girano adesso
su noi stessi e poi girano intorno al
sole o che appunto la luce ci mette un
sacco di tanto per andare da una parte
all'altra
quindi è questa un po il nocciolo tra
quello che citando a trasmettere e vi
racconto una storia bellissima cent'anni
delle equazioni di einstein ai 1900 con
indecisi era convinti che l'universo era
statico immutabile sicuramente non con
una società
turba esplosione iniziale quindi un
rilascio fermo as scrive le sue
creazioni di campo e viene fuori come
universo in espansione
impossibile l'universo è statico
aggiunge a una costante cosmologica che
ferma l'espansione dell'universo e lo
rende immobile tredici anni dopo
l'astronomo ab scopre che invece che
invece l'universo è in sé stanza nelle
galassie si allontanano scappano una
dall'altra
quindi la matematica aveva avuto ragione
malgrado la radio vaticana strano autore
giorno al graduale
la cosa importante e quindi è riuscire a
trasmettere l'intensità della scoperta
che è comunque racchiusa nel nella
scienza noi viviamo in un universo di
cui non conosciamo lui la console 4 per
cento probabilmente un universo potuto
allenarci nell'accelerazione non
sappiamo perché da dove gli viene questa
spinta probabilmente un energia oscura
nelle trame dello spazio tempo siamo
destinati a dominare sono sempre più
freddo sempre più vuoto e molto
probabilmente non ci avevano solo di
universo per pensare che ci sarà il
sesso si fa a pensare che tutte tutte le
parole i parametri di artistica siano
stati effettati per consentire a noi di
esistere
dovremo pensare a un creatore se non
pensava un creatore ci sono anche gli
altri milanisti questo è quello che ci
suggerisce la scienza quindi stiamo nel
mistero in quello che ancora non
sappiamo diceva e leibniz perché c'è
qualcosa piuttosto che niente è
sicuramente molto più complicato gestire
questo qualcosa ma è proprio perché
proprio la condizione ad ogni domanda e
proprio che ci sia dell'essere ed è
questa quindi la nostra ciò che ci
definisce e la nostra speranza e della
nostra responsabilità di conoscenza
grazie